you know I mean it's been a crazy week
it's been a lot to take in trending on
Twitter is always not the best thing
here for me I'm quite private person but
you know it's exciting you know we can
we don't really know what the future
holds for spider-man all I know is that
it's not the end of my run and we'll
continue to make great movies and I love
making it and I hope the fans will
continue to love watching them and you
know who knows what's going to happen
but I do know that it's going to be
great
everybody is Charlie I've gotten a lot
of requests for spider-man Marvel's Sony
MCU updates there's also this new
conspiracy floating around about a
supposed spider-man venom deleted scene
that they filmed in marvel forced Sony
to delete so I included that clip in
this video Tom Holland Kevin Feige doing
a bunch of interviews so we'll break it
down we're doing a new round of the
Avengers endgame and spider-man far from
home blu-ray giveaways all you have to
do to enter is be a subscriber and leave
your best spider-man venom theory in the
video there been a lot of conspiracy
theories about Sony engineering this
fall out with the deal because they're
so thirsty to have Tom Hollands
spider-man in their venom verse so I'll
try to explain what's going on what both
parties have said they've been a couple
clips with Kevin Feige talking about it
with Tom Holland talking about it the
other Marvel actors the Sony people so
number 5
spider-man is the biggest cash cow
character Sony has ever had when they
were still sharing the character with
Marvel there were so stipulations about
what they could do with Tom Hollands
spider-man while the Marvel movies were
still going on particularly Sony could
not turn around and put Tom Holland in
the first venom movie while they were
still doing Avengers endgame in
spider-man far from home that were still
coming out after the venom movie Sony
wants to build their own version of the
MCU so venom was their next best option
just one of the biggest fan favorite
characters seem like a slam dunk but
they were forced to try and make a venom
origin story that did not involve
spider-man at all which initially seemed
kind of weird and there are some
conspiracy theorists out there that
might believe there's some deleted scene
of spider-man showing up during that
movie but watching it and watching all
the behind the scenes I think it's
pretty clear that they never intended
for spider-man to be in that movie and
Kevin Feige separately never wanted
anything to do
Sony's take on the venom character first
of all venom stands alone it has its own
universe to the main and that's that was
already a complete standalone piece and
when I read it I'm quite mercenary and
quite selfish in that aspect very very
happy to have a standalone character
within the Marvel context in one world
but all to myself so I'm kind of greedy
and aspect but at the end of the day
that's that's that's kind of above my
paygrade and also it's not my daddy's
tractor so I don't know where it fits it
in the grand scheme of things so I would
never rule anything out it was a
comedian that went on the collider
podcast this week claiming that there is
a deleted scene of spider-man in the
venom movie that Marvel forced them to
take out in there were reports that
Kevin Feige did actually do some work on
the venom movie on the DL and Sony just
never said anything about it but I'll
explain what I think is going on with
that this is the clip of him talking
about that supposed to deleted
spider-man scene from the first venom
movie and actually it's benefiting Sully
too because people saw it venom because
there was rumors Tom Holland was right
and I'll tell you the truth Tom Holland
did film a scene for venom I found this
out so nice timing Marvel saw the movie
and saw that it was like take him out
take the scene out so Tom Holland did
Peter Parker was in venom not spider-man
Peter Parker what I listening to that
it's easy to buy into big conspiracy
theories but I don't think this person
had anything to do with the making of
the movie or any like real big
behind-the-scenes knowledge so unless I
see some more compelling evidence I
don't believe that Tom Holland ever
filmed a scene for the venom movie maybe
for a little while they talked about
including some more direct spider-man
references but I think that's about as
far as that went but number four never
say never I guess
when Kevin Feige was asked about venom
in the MCU while doing press for
spider-man far from home this is what he
said and I'm just quoting him directly I
think that a venom spider-man crossover
is probably up to Sony sony has both of
those characters and has venom in their
world I don't know what their plans are
for another venom movie or if they're
doing that but it seems likely at some
point there's a lot of political talk in
there because Kevin Feige definitely
knew that they were making venom to Amy
Pascal also definitely knew they were
making venom 2 but a little while ago
people asked her about
and she said there's no time line for
the movie but then turn around in just a
week or two ago they announced that Andy
Serkis has been hired as the director
and they're gonna start shooting later
this year so very clearly there's a lot
that they're not telling us
but what Kevin Feige was saying is is
that Sony had been thirsty for
spider-man vs. venom in a movie this
whole time they were just waiting for
the right opportunity after spider-man
movies were done but three I don't
believe the conspiracy theory that Sony
wanted this outcome spider-man leaving
the MCU just to legitimize their venom
spider-verse franchise but I do think he
came up in negotiations and had the
first venom movie bombed at the box
office that would have only made things
worse for spider-man of the MCU then
Sony would have been like we really need
this crown jewel spider-man character we
need some of that money spider-man has
always been Sony's biggest box-office
earner in the way that Kevin Feige has
talked about the character in the past
he was meant to be the crown jewel in
Kevin Feige 's cap two billion dollar
franchises at the MCU if spider-man was
the one character that he was really
after this clip pretty clearly tells you
how important spider-man was to the MCU
bringing spider-man into the universe
where he belongs as all the fans know
interact with other characters for the
very first time and it was it seemed
like the right time to do it spider-man
is the biggest Marvel character he is
the jewel in the crown such an amazing
icon he is a very different type of hero
because he is quite simply the greatest
superhero of all time so - as of right
now Sony is making spider-man 3 without
Marvel they're moving forward on their
timeline they're gonna release it summer
2021 the film will not take place in the
MCU continuity but per Tom Hollands
comments in Sony's comments separately
it will carry forward the story that
they set up during spider-man far from
home - a lot of MCU characters and
references there was the scene with
spider-man and happy on the plane where
they talked about missing Ironman and
happy says he would have done what he
did if he didn't think that he would be
around to carry his legacy forward when
Kevin Feige and Marvel were still gonna
make spider-man 3 in spider-man 4 that
moment was actually going to be very
important for informing where the
franchise would be going but now it
seems like that's not the case they're
not going to erase what happened during
spider-man home
the other Avengers films Captain America
Civil War they just won't be referencing
it a whole lot and you won't see happy
hogan in that next movie all the Marvel
actors even John Favreau
were talking about how disappointed they
were but they do seem kind of hopeful
that things will work out eventually
well I guess happy single again after
all that time took 10 years for him to
get into a good relationship ah you know
it's still early days and I'm as a fan
I'm cautiously hopeful that something
will come together because I think all
the fans want to see those characters
together I don't mean happy and May I
mean I mean Spidey with with the MCU
so you know it's still early days and
things you know you don't know is what
you read isn't always indicative of
where things are right now so I
hopefully I'll find out more while I'm
here but uh but as a fan I'm hopeful
that you know cautiously optimistic
holding out hope that this isn't the
final chapter of that story separately
James Gunn also talked about this Marvel
Sony spider-man drama as a lover's
quarrel
temporary setback spider-man would be
back in the MCU eventually but there's
no clip of him talking about it and he's
not part of those discussions so that's
just him speculating on what's going to
happen but number one I've seen a lot of
you commenting about this there were
rumors this week about Tom Holland
filming a scene for venom two this week
and I think that they were fake because
they haven't even started shooting the
movie yet so how could he have filmed a
cameo when they haven't even started
venom two yet but I do think that
they're going to leave room at the end
of that movie for a spider-man reference
they wouldn't film that - the last
possible second shrouded in deepest
secrecy in a bunker somewhere in Atlanta
or wherever they decide to film venom -
Andy Serkis was just hired as the
director and he was hyping up the movies
saying that they'd be taking the venom
character in a completely new direction
from the previous film but when he was
talking about that spider-man was still
in the MCU as before the big deal
fallout so I think that that's
confirmation at least initially the
Spider Man was never meant to be part of
their venom to plan but because of
what's happened recently that could
change between now and when they start
filming the movie later this year but it
still meant to the venom versus carnage
so at most there would be a Spider Man
post-credit scene of some kind where he
shows up in a news broadcast or is
mentioned by someone spider-man 3 is him
on the run so it does give Sonia logical
reason to take the character out of New
York City and get him in venom together
in venom 3 or spider-man 4 but as of
right now they tend to keep the movies
relatively simple so whatever venom
versus carnage or venom 2 is going to be
I don't think that's gonna change that
much because of this spider-man fallout
and they're not gonna shoot horn too
much venom stuff into spider-man 3 all
of a sudden Tom Holland did say they
already have the story locked down for
that they've already pitched it to Sony
and I've already done a couple videos
about that so I'll link that at the end
of this funny enough Sony is releasing
that extended director's cut of
spider-man far from home in theaters
today it's actually happening tonight I
will do a video about the new footage
that they show off in case you don't
want to go see that it even though the
timing does seem kind of unfortunate I
don't think that Marvel secretly leaked
the news about this fallout with the
deal to torpedo their re-release it is
fun to try and watch their interviews to
see who might be lying about something
and what they're trying to hide what
they're not saying so they're any big
questions that you guys have about this
or spider-man videos you want me to make
about what's happening in the future
just let me know in the comments
congratulations Jason Oetken you're the
giveaway winner for my last big Marvel
video please email me on the about page
of my channel so I can get your details
everyone click here for my breakdown of
the new avatar the last airbender
Netflix footage that just leaked of them
filming episode 1 and click here for my
breakdown of the Marvel phase 4 teaser
from this past weekend thank you so much
for watching everybody stay awesome I'll
see you guys tonight
[Music]